[Musique]
je
bonjour chaque jour nous vous présentons
les finalistes du challenge des
créateurs d'entreprise de belles
entreprises portées par de beaux
créateurs qui créent l'emploi
c'est la catégorie création d'emplois
[Musique]
- mon but c'était avoir travaillé à voir
l'entreprise quoi
on partait de la compétition mais en
compte la c1 c'est un défi en soi
[Musique]
bonjour nous attendons nous à me
travailler un petit peu avec le monde
pourquoi la crise est entre pays où
seuls perdants scott parcours annoncé
travailler à l'âge de 12 ans à 22 ans en
larmes première entreprise ça a maintenu
donc après c'est à 50 2 malheureux
rouvert mon entreprise je vais dire oui
me pense que mal un petit peu plus
jamais j'ai plus d'expérience
du coup bon ben voilà passé un petit peu
aussi par pôle emploi
la boutique de gestion fiat ou bien si
pas de diplôme pas de crp travailler sur
des chantiers et recréer une entreprise
a 52 ans c'est déjà pas mal
arrivé à l'as
[Musique]
du coup les conditions de vie ici on est
un simple ans et j'ai un autre sentir
tap
il faut dire des normands comment vous
faites j'ai passés par un pôle emploi
d'été en plus vous appreniez les gars
noté habiter travailler ensemble depuis
longtemps
donc voilà dit pourquoi pas après un
entreprise pour faire connaître ces gars
là parce qu'il travaille bien dans ce
secteur il me semble que c'est un
secteur qui connaît la crise ont créé
une offre emploi c'est d'affirmer encore
parce qu'il m'a frappé c'est sa capacité
à ne pas renoncer
depuis son parcours la force de
caractère qui développe et surtout son
enthousiasme va vous la faire grandir
encore son entreprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
était dans l'automobile en 98 donc dans
un société de lavage auto donc ensuite
j'ai travaillé pour automobiles réunion
pendant 12 ans plus le temps passe et
donc je me suis dis donc pourquoi pas
ouvrir et créer les emplois ont pu et
j'ai mis toutes mes économies
cette année donc on a décidé justement
de voir réunion entreprendre pour nous
aider justement pour eux avancé les
fonds pour eux les travaux
comme vous voyez aujourd'hui donc
on est exactement dans nos futurs locaux
combien d'employés
vous allez cette folie qui sont à temps
plein qui sont attendus je me donne
vraiment à fond pour faire avancer
l'entreprise essayer de favoriser les
jeunes créent des emplois justement
c'est au bureau de ces mobiles beau rôle
en stoppant les projets de recrutement à
venir
on a déjà des projets de recrutement
justement quand les locaux seront
terminés parce qu'on décidera de mettre
en place de la mécanique justement ça
sera en début janvier mais que la
mécanique l'egypte petit révision
plaquettes
enfin l'avenir positif c'est de gagner
justement le challenge pour faire un peu
des travaux dans les bâtiments
je tiens c'est un jeune chef
d'entreprise est très dynamique très
sérieux pour moi c'est une entreprise
qui est bien positionné sur son marché
avec tous les bureaux cas au tour avec
beaucoup de clientèle qui a un tel
potentiel
on ressent bien que la question des
emplois et une grande importance thomas
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de la grande finale dans
l'hémicycle du département qui sera le
lauréat de la catégorie création
d'emplois
[Musique]
avec moi moi m patel le chargé de
mission partenariat à pôle emploi
bonsoir soir alors ce sont des petites
entreprises
elle ne crée pas beaucoup d'emplois
parce que ça cette dynamique a vraiment
un impact sur les chiffres du chômage
vous avez chaque année au toit de 5min
création d'entreprise à la réunion il
faut savoir que dans ces cinq mines
création d'entreprise vous avez à peu
près 30 à 40% selon les années qui sont
portées par des demandeurs d'emploi donc
au niveau de pôle emploi on a une vraie
volonté politique d'aller accompagner la
création d'entreprise et nous versons à
ce titre à peu près 7 millions d'euros
chaque année aux demandes d'emploi pour
les aider les accompagner vers cette
création la applaudissent et là ils sont
là ce sont vraiment des baux candidats
des beaux finalistes de la catégorie
création d'emplois on peut les applaudir
encore fait gabbud en entreprise gave
dans wilfried kla entreprises scheider
tôt
tous les deux ils ont créé de plusieurs
emplois c'est vraiment magnifique
pour cette année le prix de la création
d'emplois est décerné à monsieur fred
cav aux dents pour l'applaudir
félicitations à ces beautés de voir une
belle ouvrage grave en soi
cachés
pourquoi vous avez décidé je vais créer
mon entreprise je vais je vais prendre
les rênes de l'entrepreneuriat mais
parce que j'avais senti et d'appui de me
mange annales il avait cette capacité là
mais j'avais une éducation un peu
difficile
arrivées trouve à l'école on va dire
maintenant c'est l'expérience je joue
beaucoup sur l'expérience et il faut
dire le créole à la réunion nou lé kapab
nou lé kapab mais n'a beaucoup yaws pas
à mon âge si atout dans le bâtiment mais
nous on a un bon potentiel
espérons vous avez compris l'esprit
c'est à vous jouez bonne soirée et à
bientôt
[Musique]